are you actually are you actually
running yeah seven miles in seven miles
I was uh I did run like technically a
half marathon but I didn't like do it
like I didn't yeah enter a race for it
nice yeah nice but I'm not there
it's better but that's why I'm afraid of
the knee thing why don't you do a half
Mary I am planning on it I want to do
one where I don't tell people that I'm
doing it and then just do it and it's
good and then just okay doing things for
a
person's content man everything's
content man yeah half of it is bragging
about it yeah everything is content dude
you gotta put the sticker on your car
dude oh man you're looking for personal
growth what are you [__] lame you
guys you guys plan on popping kids
anytime soon the hell what bro I can't
ask that that's a normal question right
he has kids oh [__] I have five children
they all run in
different like different
professionalities it was like 20 years
old yeah what the [__] hey man you can
draft at 17. yeah yeah
yeah No One's Gonna answer them yeah
damn never mind
oh yeah I wanna
definitely how many you want to do
I don't know we'll see
how hard the first one that was like bad
phrasing how many kids you want to do
you just like you know play by ear
see what the first one's like right the
first one's gonna be a little weird
always you think so yeah I think my
kid's gonna be weird no no no your kids
your kids are gonna be fine probably
yeah you ever need someone to watch them
uh no I'm good I used to work at a
daycare really yeah
were you giving those kids weed like
what you just give them Market t-shirts
yeah I made this one your face
are you tripping about how you would
like balance kid life and then your
content life yeah a little bit but well
you gotta admit your content life no the
kid is the contact yeah I'm not gonna
milk my kid is that what you just said
what the [__] Waleed Jesus just after
you tell us you lived in a daycare
I don't live there I used to work there
no you lived there
I used to be in charge of the yeah
you're bad
turning off the power of everything
two-year-olds and then the the after
school kids oh yeah what's that mean
yeah what do you mean the the after
school they're the ones that the parents
don't really like it yeah
dude do you did you spend time after
school daycare no I mean working there
you know did you
no I don't think so I guess you're in
sports that's kind of yeah that is kind
of like it's kind of but straight up
daycare that [__] was chaos huh like
that's it man I remember at a time at a
period you're like
you like see kids going home with
parents you're like [__] that seems way
better yeah you know I have to go to
this thing with all these kids and like
half of them are just screaming and
psycho and they're like all right read
books you're like these kids don't read
They're bullies they're horrible people
yeah
Sunshine Daycare shut them out yeah so
this is an after-school thing yeah so
like what grades
you can learn first
second okay I said for one grid but I
was very [__] I was like a passive
kid I just asked the uh the lady at the
thing to just draw me bubble letters
because I didn't know how to do it damn
that was it and then I just sat at the
table and colored I did a did it did my
time in daycare
no I remember dude that Meme like you're
hurting stop it you're hurting her like
that was me and I think like the summer
before first grade
uh there was this counselor I like loved
her they all had nicknames and she was
like she was Taz like the Tasmanian
devil that's funny and uh she was like
oh that was like like I was Mr Wally
yeah okay you have fun names Mr Wally
yeah that's kind of cute
why they would have missed her I was a
man I don't know
like brown guy they're like how about Mr
Magic Carpet
the kids are saying that
she was hooking up with this other
counselor like in the [__] company
van okay I remember everyone was just
like did you know that well everyone was
just like playing with toys and some kid
goes by the window and he's like yo
Taz is
the dude's name was Slater all the kids
ran to the window and I was too short I
couldn't like see him and everyone's
just like narrating what's going on I'm
like
[Laughter]
there's a thing on ours called Bounce
House Fridays remember I was in charge
and there was the two-year-olds all in
the bounce house having a great time
yeah and during your break another
teacher is supposed to watch the kids
while you eat your lunch or whatever
yeah now I guess at some point during
the transition one of the two-year-olds
got out and went behind the bounce house
and unplugged it
and then I saw I'm watching all this
while I'm eating lunch and I see it
slowly like deflate and like all the
kids are screaming for their lives and
the teacher didn't know what was going
on she was like an older lady or
whatever dude I ran out I jumped into
the bell's house I grabbed the kids by
their legs
what would have happened if they would
have died
no bounce house is huge you could just
plugged it back well no it was too late
like a balloon
is it pretty heavy it's like I think
they were like suffocate if you're two
years old yeah I think about a
two-year-old yeah
I mean for a tweet no
damn I was gonna say it's like
a pretty great way to go
that's a horrible thing to say yeah the
last kid I remember I was holding the
bounce house in my arms and he was
coming towards me crying
and then after that they never they
never went back on the bounce house
they're all traumatized oh [__]
damn more bouncy Friday that image for
those kids must have been so crazy
kebab
all right
by their legs beware of deflation
although it may not seem like it bounce
houses are actually quite heavy a small
bounce house weighs 50 no death slow I
don't see any deaths I will look it up
but I'm sure I don't think a death at
least one wow I don't know yeah why
don't we lay a 50 pound dumbbell on a
two-year-old and see what happens
because I'm a hero I'd be kind of
worried about that kid that unplugged it
he's like yeah
and you were eating lunch the whole time
no I was watching the whole thing
from a distance you're getting the last
bites in you're like damn that'd be
crazy
who put a 911 conspiracy today that we
have a brown guy give us some sports
stories boys sports stories all of you
was you was yammering about Formula One
you're like there's no drama oh yeah
dude I was watching I finished all five
seasons it's One race I know yeah and
then this weekend's a race that I will
watch what time is it at
um probably seven in the morning get F1
TV you weenie so then I could watch it
later in the day yeah but then you just
don't see any spoilers on social no just
don't look get up at nine watch it while
you have breakfast your tomato breakfast
okay listen I'll tell you right now and
when you go play F on TV if the race is
longer than an hour and a half red flag
someone crashed
okay so you know you have something to
look forward to I got all the
pronunciations of the names wrong I call
it Louise Hamilton Luis
you have a thing for framing people's
Latinos
Mercedes just
[Laughter]
Louise Hamilton what else he said uh
Alfonso Alfonso oh that's not right no
Alonso oh got that one right you added a
letter
uh I got verstappen right I got Le
Claire it's uh Charles lecleric LeClaire
no c c [__] that one up yeah there we go
there's another one it's French but I'm
into it I'm gonna watch this week I'll
probably even wake up at seven I'll beat
you I'll text you back go ahead and
spoil it for you bro
spoil it you're [__] up dude hey
I might be following some NASCAR this
year
I might be trying to follow some NASCAR
follow yeah yeah what do you mean I
realized NASCAR you want you want
[__] drama oh yeah okay oh yeah oh
yeah those dudes just crash like on
purpose yeah yeah like I always knew it
but like I never took the time to watch
it and just seeing them go like last
corner just being like yeah I'm taking
the inside
they just know each other they're like
oh this this fool took me out last race
so this race
foreign
season three or four Jules yeah but they
continued the race after he died psycho
that's [__] nuts he died in the race
yes like and they knew he was dead uh
and I don't think at the time maybe like
he crashed and they were like there's no
oh they did yeah that injury was
horrendous dude yeah but then they
continued
the [__] yeah it's insane uh I'll put it
this way because that crash that
introduced halos
okay
that was recently yeah whoa like a
couple years ago basically
more or less damn yeah you guys should
sponsor and NASCAR a NASCAR yeah they're
not that expensive yeah actually that'd
be cool yeah I would definitely do the
who did it the super mega boys did it
but there's crashed yeah like they made
a whole thing about it they got there
they were super excited they Daft at the
driver like yo you're gonna crush it
right and then crashed in like the first
five last six so then what like their
investment is yeah they spent like 30
grand and that's it for the car they
kept the hood of it which is cool we
should sponsor it but like wrap it in
like one of those [__] like weeaboo
like hentai girl
some [__] Sailor Moon [__]
all the other sponsors are like yo hey
Home Depot's like we can't put our [__]
on that all the other drivers are like
God damn
just look at those [__] plows the
field dude